happy tuesday everyone
well it's official
so with the help of the fbi the
democratic party just endorsed donald
trump for president of the united states
well done
but i wonder if the president will
profoundly accept the nomination for
president of the united states
i profoundly accept this nomination for
president of the united states
it's happening
yeah that raid was a real smart move
you want to take a larger than life
character and make him even larger you
raid his frickin house
basically they just gave popeye a
55-ounce can of spinach
they just gave hunter biden a brand new
crack pipe and a high-speed internet
access
they just gave me a book of 1001 poop
jokes
because the raid not only angers
republicans it energizes them and it
energizes trump and unlike all the other
shows we actually have tape of the raid
[Applause]
[Music]
now
the raid is
it's wrong but you got to keep your
sense of humor on this for a reason part
of the strategy of the raid is to get
you to react so that they can then cover
your anger as danger
the press has already sounded the alarm
over the rage on pro-trump message
boards they're ready to go they say as
if you're gonna do commit acts of
violence so don't get mad
instead sympathize the dems want trump
back and for good reason they can't
survive without him they are drowning
and he is their oxygen you know they're
just too boring and uninspiring if
trump's filet mignon democrats are warm
tapioca
maybe it's because their current
leader's brains are warm tapioca
so
they'll do anything to keep the
spotlight off him i mean can you blame
them this guy gets into fights with his
own clothes
roll it pedro
[Music]
yes
oh my god
wait wait wait there's more
give him time he'll remember where the
arms go someday
thankfully it was a jacket and not his
pants
but it's also kind of scary when it
takes mere seconds for joe to forget
that he just shook someone's hand
[Applause]
now our great speaker our partner
that's the craziest thing i've ever seen
my god no wonder they hide him like a
cold sore at a kissing booth
what gives joe
leave me alone i like ice cream
come on man
i got a chocolate chip
of course while much of the country will
be pissed off over the raid the left
embraced the news like it was a box of
kleenex at a sperm bank tomorrow is the
day when you're going to want to buy the
physical copy of the newspaper you're
going to want to buy it and fold it
carefully no one is above the law not
even a president or former president of
the united states this is a night where
you are going to remember where you were
he also has the lying advantage the
government's not going to lie but donald
trump will lie profusely and the fact
that people uh
weak people are running around going oh
what are we going to do they're saying
ugly things on fox news
like what do you expect
like this guy's going to be brought to
justice he's broken the law everybody
knows that
well hip hip hooray for tyranny
and this from people who do nothing but
whine about how our democracy is under
assault what absolute jerk-offs
so if the raid is about classified
documents then you didn't need a raid at
all but like biden's son they also know
what makes for exciting video
and as andy mccarthy points out in the
new york post it's likely the white
house is pressuring the justice
department to link trump criminally to
january 6.
sadly the fbi seems like another
institution polluted by politics
except unlike college lefties they
punish you with arrests not by spelling
your name wrong on your latte
they investigate some people but not
others i could go through the list but
you've heard it at least on this network
you have if they were any deeper in the
swamp they'd have alligators for baby
mamas
that's disgusting
and especially after pushing the russian
collusion hoax how can you give them a
pass on this now
i mean they show up at the house they go
through all of his stuff including his
safe which is why i don't have a safe
i keep everything in between my mattress
and box spring
thank god that doll is easy to inflate
some levity but it seems like all of our
institutions are imploding like a twix
bar in stacy abram's back pocket
maybe it's due to woke-ism or
anti-trumpism or plain old elitism it's
a far cry from the good old days when
they knew to keep politics at bay
and if they don't come out with one
major smoking gun from that raid and i
mean major like a video of trump french
kissing putin or don jr with pelosi in a
headlock as eric rifles through her
purse then they're going to have a
country that's more pissed off than r
kelly after two courts of snapple
it's disgusting this isn't a policy
decision this is a former president's
house being raided can you imagine doing
this to obama or biden in a few years or
hillary come to think of it they should
raid her place in chappaqua just to find
evidence if bill's ever been there
we know he likes to leave dna around
[Music]
who crossed the line
the fbi it seems thinks they're the
country and they're not they're not even
a third world country despite their
banana republic antics america right now
is a beautiful car whose steering keeps
pulling to the left and the engine light
has come on for the tenth time and
they've run out of electrical tape to
hide it
we know there's a problem under the hood
it's all these supposedly neutral
institutions having now chosen a team
it would cost us too much to get a whole
new car but we should at least replace
the drivetrain in a couple of months
last night's raid was just another
example in a pattern of one-way
persecution where they pay you a visit
and it's up to you to prove your
innocence it's the same mentality with
the irs agents hey if you don't cheat
you have nothing to nothing to hide so
who will they go for next maybe you
maybe me all i know is in preparation
for the raid i've moved my collection of
adult-oriented beanie babies out of the
house
some people wouldn't understand
let's welcome tonight's
she never blunders when she hosts
outnumbered host of the faulkner focus
and outnumbered co-host harris [ __ ]
his pronouns are he and his but his
scruff says daddy vice president of
public relations for z labs chris barron
she's like a doormat thin welcoming and
often found laying on your porch fox's
contributor cat tip
finally he wanted to be a football
kicker but they kept running out of
balls my massive sidekick in the nwa
world television champions
[Applause]
so harris i'm sure you've been talking
about this a lot what is your dupe
do you think the story is about
classified documents or something else
going on
well if it were about classified
documents then those that he had already
handed over whether he knew they were in
those boxes or not
would be part of the argument well then
you keep talking about how to get more
of whatever is there
but her griff jenkins one of our
correspondents here on fox news about an
hour and a half ago reported that
according to fox news sources
the negotiations of some sort had broken
down and that's why they got the warrant
it's that but that's like going nuclear
but that sounds like something that they
could simply say out loud without
jeopardizing the case yeah i mean the
doj is a mess right now
and stayed silent all day yeah if this
if if this is a screw-up it's one of the
biggest screw-ups of all time and i
include your jacket shirt combo chris
this is beautiful are you kidding me i
know you're jealous i know you're
jealous i'll dress you next to me on
this
what do you i mean here's the thing
you should be angry about this but if
you get angry then you fit into their
mode haha they're angry what's next well
there was a boston globe article like
that came out mid-afternoon that was
like the right-wing anger and violence
brewing the reaction like which is of
course what they want right here's the
thing that drives me the craziest about
this all these people who says we have
to give the doj and the fbi the benefit
of the doubt
absolute
if you're going to cross this line if
you're going to raid the not just a
former president but the chief political
opposition the guy who's most likely to
be running against biden in 2024 the fbi
and doj have a an obligation to come out
and say what the hell is going on why
was this necessary why did they cross
this line we shouldn't be sitting here
guessing like oh is it over documents
there's something else going on if
you're going to cross this line you
better come forward and you better make
it clear there was a damn good reason to
do this this isn't this is not normal
it's not normal
cat i mean do you ever worry about
getting raided anything i mean why
should we like now you have to think
about that because they rated a
president
that means they do you some of us have
always been thinking about it
i mean just i mean
hearing all these people talk about the
concerns about too powerful of law
enforcement agencies federally
libertarians are over here like yeah
we've been talking about that and if you
are concerned about federal law
enforcement agencies potentially being
politicized then you shouldn't stand for
giving them the kind of power that makes
that possible i've seen a lot of
republicans today talk about those
concerns who are you know republican
politicians who are the same people who
for example repeatedly voted to
repeatedly reauthorize the patriot act
so i hope that there's something to be
learned from this in terms of uh seeing
what can happen regardless of what side
you're on when these agencies have far
more power than they should would you be
okay with disbanding the fbi i think the
fbi has far too much power far too much
power yeah and i think i mean i will
admit that i am probably one of the
people that you're talking about in the
sense that thank you no i mean it's like
now they're using the patriot act or or
would their authority to track down
citizens in the united states i mean
like parents at school boards exactly
exactly yes yes
so tyrus
what are your thoughts on this i love
this yeah
this is phenomenal
this would get me hyped i'd be in i'd be
outside not clapping all right game on
okay
you got nothing you ain't got the
bookkeeper you got nothing yeah you know
i'd be i'd have fun with it yeah i got
the best lawyer you'll be fbiing in
alaska and i'm done you i'd find every
cliche from every movie we've been there
we've done this before you had me on
russia it was joan of arc behar came on
and said we have the papers and we got
them yeah we got it we got them they got
nothing
so this is again you've inspired i
you have to look at things
i love spike i like spiked stores i have
a spike career
we're gonna have a spike president it's
i couldn't be happier
you go into my house you try to
embarrass me
you the the man who cannot be
embarrassed yes it's so true well and
trump went for president because they
said obama made jokes about him one joke
yes at a party yeah yeah
we're going to be president
just hey
you literally you rung the bell game on
he's fired up so i'm going to sit back
and just watch there might be a spite
position for me in this
so yeah
[Music]
so tonight
representative jim banks and about a
dozen other republicans are meeting at
bedminster
right and i'm just wondering as you talk
about it i mean that is a galvanizing
point maybe they didn't agree
on policy and maybe they haven't agreed
but i mean he legitimately now has
brought more people together just
because he wasn't home yeah amazing
that's all i mean do you think they
would have done this had he been
standing there i don't i don't know
about that listen i would have been
worried if nancy pelosi didn't come out
and say you know no one's above the law
for real yeah for real yeah
[Applause]
stock yeah
i don't remember the the president
getting the dui and destroying
somebody's car and
not being charged yeah so yeah the other
funny thing about those stock options
nancy pelosi what did you say uh
presidential documents should be
preserved i think wasn't she the one
that tore up trump's speech
anyway
like i said it's all good man
24.
just it's entertaining to me watch the
left defend the fbi this is the same fbi
that just tried to destroy martin luther
king yeah they spent years wiretapping
him trying to set him up sending him
blackmail letters
they are saying the fbi you can't even
question them and the fbi has a long
history of being used as political pawns
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else